[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur cher Jean-Baptiste blanc mes
chers collègues monsieur le ministre
alors nous débutons cette discussion
générale je souhaiterais vous lire
quelques phrases
en matière d'artificialisation des sols
le gouvernement propose des objectifs
ambitieux mais se trompent sur la
méthode il propose un dispositif
extrêmement centralisé peut emprise avec
la réalité du territoire français qui se
caractérise par des dynamiques
d'artificialisation très différentes il
est à craindre que la compétence
régionale ne donne davantage de poids au
revendications des métropoles et des
zones urbanisées au détriment des
territoires ruraux en outre la notion
d'artificialisation nette n'est
aujourd'hui ni définie ni mesurée par
les collectivités ou par l'État enfin la
loi fixe des délais absolument
irréalistes ces mots ne m'appartiennent
pas ce sont ceux de la commission des
affaires économiques il y a déjà de cela
presque deux ans au moment où notre
assemblée avait examiné le projet de loi
climat résilience il est frappant de
constater qu'avant même l'adoption de
cette loi fleuve en l'absence d'étude
fourni par le gouvernement nous avions
déjà pointé du doigt les problématiques
qui nous réunissent aujourd'hui
ce n'est un secret pour personne que la
mise en œuvre d'usane est aujourd'hui
extrêmement compliqué à la fois par des
problèmes d'ordre presque techniques
comme en ce qui concerne la nomenclature
des sols artificialisés et d'autres
éminemment politique comme le degré de
contraintes du document régional où les
équilibres entre territoires je pense
que ces problèmes proviennent au moins
en partie d’une concertation
insuffisante avec les élus au moment de
la loi climat résilience puis d'un
certain défauts d'écoute de la part du
gouvernement le Sénat avait déjà proposé
certaines évolutions des l'examen de la
loi en 2021 comme une territorialisation
plus poussée ou un décalage du
calendrier de révision des documents
d'urbaines
avaient pourtant été rejetées dans la
suite de la navette il nous a donc fallu
remettre la loi climat résilience sur le
métier d'abord dans le cadre de la loi
3DS pour prévoir les délais
supplémentaires devant l'impossibilité
des conférences
à tenir le calendrier fixé par la loi
puis il a fallu que les décrets
d'applications soient attaqués devant le
Conseil d'État pour que le gouvernement
admette l'inapplicabilité de la
nomenclature des sols artificialisée et
les carences du décret relatif au srade
le chemin qui nous amène ici dans
l'hémicycle pour examiner ce texte a
donc été long il y a désormais consensus
sur le fait qu'il faut modifier la loi
et je pense que nous sénateurs et
sénatrice avons fait un travail
important pour mettre ce sujet en haut
de l'agenda comme nous y en joignait les
élus locaux
je veux ce titre saluer le travail
important de notre rapporteur
Jean-Baptiste blanc au sein des murs du
palais comme en dehors sur le terrain
pour expliquer éclaircir améliorer la
loi sur le zan je remercie aussi et
évidemment l'ensemble de nos collègues
issus de tous les bancs qui ont
participé à la mission conjointe de
contrôle créée par le Sénat en septembre
dernier qui a abouti au dépôt de la
proposition de loi que nous examinons
aujourd'hui dès l'examen de la loi
climat résilience nous avions adopté une
approche collective avec le rapport de
Monsieur blanc monsieur Redon sarrazzi
et Madame Loisier l'objectif zan à
l'épreuve des territoires nous nous
sommes tous retrouvés en septembre
dernier autour de cette mission forma
inhabituelle qui témoigne de la manière
dont le zan envahit aujourd'hui
toutes les politiques publiques tous nos
débats de commission tous nos
territoires le texte qui a émergé des
travaux de la mission vise à répondre de
manière concrète aux difficultés
d'applications
et d'un travail approfondie sur les
données je regrette à ce titre que nous
n'ayons pas disposé de ces données
précises dès l'examen de la loi car
elles auraient pu nous éclairer plus
précisément sur les choix que nous
opérions cet enjeu de transparence et
d'études de l'impact des textes des
fondamentales je tiens à le dire ici
devant nous monsieur le ministre cette
transparence sera aussi essentielle pour
la suite de l'application du zan et je
pense notamment au traitement des grands
projets ou encore à la collecte des
données d'artificialisation je le disais
le chemin qui a mené à cette proposition
de loi a été long malgré certaines
annonces au cours des derniers mois
c'est le Sénat qui a dû prendre
l'initiative de déposer un texte pour
faire bouger les lignes législatives
nous avons perdu un temps précieux même
si la finalement contribuait à faire
mûrir les réflexions de part et d'autre
je sais l'un moins le ministre
Christophe Béchu ainsi que le ministre
fort qui ont accepté le dialogue initié
par le Sénat autour de ce sujet complexe
qu'ils ont hérité du gouvernement
précédent et je remercie aussi le
gouvernement d'avoir demandé le recours
à la procédure accélérée sur ce texte ce
qui nous permettra en cas d'accord
d'apporter plus rapidement les réponses
qu'attendent les élus locaux qui se
retrouvent en ce moment dans une
situation intermédiaire qui est
difficilement vivable je voudrais dire
un mot plus général de la philosophie du
texte présenté par la mission conjointe
de contrôle que nous examinerons
aujourd'hui d'abord c'est un texte qui
visait apporter davantage de pragmatisme
et d'efficacité les imprécisions et le
formalisme de la loi climat résilience
compliquent énormément la tâche des élus
locaux qui finalement sont les seuls à
porter la responsabilité pratique de
l'atteinte des objectifs sans pour
autant en avoir les outils il faut donc
nous assurer que ce que la loi met en
place est effectivement applicable que
l'on ne crée pas un monstre admin
interactif ni des situations absurdes
c'est aussi la raison pour laquelle nous
plaidons pour davantage de temps car
toutes les personnes auditionnées nous
ont dit clairement que la qualité de la
réflexion en amont permettra d'aller
plus vite et plus efficacement ensuite
cela justifie enfin d'offrir de nouveaux
outils juridiques pour que les élus
étaient efficacement effectivement la
maîtrise concrète de l'artificialisation
comme le sursis à statué ou le droit de
préemption spécifique aux ânes enfin
c'est un texte qui vise à éviter la
création de nouvelles inégalités le
dispositif de territorialisation si
absolument nécessaire peut présenter
certains risques notamment celui que les
grandes métropoles comme les communes
urbaines captent une grande partie des
enveloppes futures d'artificialisation
c'est un enjeu fondamental il faut
permettre à chaque territoire
urbain comme rural de réaliser son
potentiel si le zan est perçu comme une
nouvelle inégalité comme une mise sous
cloche des territoires ruraux au profit
de la consommation des eaux urbaines
comme organisant le sous-développement
des certains territoires alors il
échouera il faut aussi prendre en compte
les conséquences sociales du zan que
l'on pressant mais qui ne sont pas
encore tangibles car il entraînera une
redistribution de la richesse des
patrimoine attention ne pas créer des
gilets jaunes d'usage les collectivités
seront en coller mirlines pour gérer les
conséquences concrètes c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous proposons des
mécanismes de pas réservé de surface
minimale de développement communal conçu
comme de vrais garanties au profit des
territoires notamment ruraux il faut
aussi que le système que nous mettons en
place pour les 30 prochaines années soit
assez souples pour évoluer pour prendre
en compte l'imprévu et le nécessaire
logique décennale ne veut pas dire
immobilisme il faut pouvoir accueillir
les grands projets de demain s'adapter
aux évolutions démographiques ou
économiques adapter les approches
l'architecture du Zen est aujourd'hui
rigide il nous faut y apporter de la
souplesse c'est l'objectif des
dispositifs comme la part réservée
prévue par le et l'intention derrière
notre proposition d'une gouvernance plus
large qui puisse suivre et adapter les
trajectoires le chemin était long il
n'est pas terminé vous le savez monsieur
le ministre que le gouvernement a du
pain sur la planche pour aller au bout
du sujet du zan sans hypocrisie et sans
idée préconçues mais je suis sûr qu'en
semble nous y arriveront il faudra c'est
indéniable rebattre les cartes de la
fiscalité de l'aménagement et du
logement il faudra dégager de nouvelles
ressources pour que les collectivités
territoriales et les moyens concrets de
piloter leur artificialisation de
renaturer de traiter les friches un fond
vert ni suffira pas ce sont des
ressources durables d'ingénierie de
fiscalité locale qu'il faut mobiliser je
n'évoquerai pas les constats très francs
de la Cour des comptes concernant les
moyens de l'état des concentré nous
savons tous ici que malgré les bonnes
volontés locales les collectivités sont
bien souvent très seul face à leurs
obligations nous souhaitons que l'État
prenne ses responsabilités pour que la
décentralisation n'en n'est pas que le
nom le chemin est encore trop long mais
j'espère nous espérons que nos
discussions aujourd'hui permettront de
faire aboutir bientôt ce texte qui sera
un grand pas vers une application plus
efficace et plus apaisée du zan au coeur
de nos territoires je remercie encore
une fois l'ensemble de nos collègues sur
tous les banques qui dans la commission
spéciale elles nous ont accordé leur
confiance leur construction leur esprit
constructif ainsi que notre rapporteur
Jean-Baptiste blanc pour son écoute et
sa compétence monsieur le ministre nous
entamons le chemin à cette à ce moment à
cet instant il faut que nous
aboutissions dans l'intérêt des
territoires et je suis sûr que nous y
arriverons une fois de plus merci à vous